[Music]
when rioting broke out in Minneapolis
last week it created unexpected problems
for people living in some neighborhoods
many already suffering from the effects
of code 19 to add to their struggles
grocery stores were either looted or
just closed their doors and public
transportation wasn't running that cut
off the food supply for many that is
until a middle school parent put out a
call for help and people responded in
epic fashion Jamie yuccas has the story
it's almost as if a tornado came through
and just knocked down businesses that
had food for people days after riots and
fires ripped through Minneapolis as part
of the response to the police involved
killing of George Floyd residents were
left with an absence of essential
businesses I've never seen anything like
this before in the area I think through
those families affected by the closures
there was two three four
grocery stores closed within less than a
mile of area in this community as well
as drug stores and everything so they're
just literally became a food desert in
24 hours
Rob Williams is the founder and
executive director of the Sheraton story
a nonprofit focusing on feeding kids
throughout Minnesota during food gaps
like on weekends or over holidays and
now when no grocery stores exist
Williams partnered with a local middle
school after a community member put a
call out on social media to help feed
their neighbors the response was
remarkable educator like knowing that
our kids will be because of the stores
currently being shut down this hit my
heart a lot eighty five bags of food
were needed more than 29,000 bags of
food were donated throughout the day we
estimate we collected 18 semi-truck
loads worth of food which is a
staggering amount of food honestly I'm
really emotional right now I'm still
thankful that our neighbors are coming
together it's the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen we had 14 blocks of cars
lined up to drop off food we ended up in
opening another site down the street
from the middle school at a part to also
accept items and then
after we had the items we were able to
turn it around and start distributing
the bags back out to the community back
out to the families and and kids that
needed it the most when trying to get in
in anything that we can get right now
like Luis he lost his local grocery
store to a fire he doesn't make the
situation better
to make me feel like old people really
do have a heart that's what I think this
was an unprecedented situation and it
required an unprecedented response which
is what we saw from the community on
Sunday and it will continue to need
require a unprecedent response going
forward and that will require some food
for thought for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie yuccas Minneapolis
neighbor helping neighbor Michelle I
don't know how to say it any differently
than that well I tell you a lot of
people out of out there with heart
sometimes they just need to know what to
do with it just knowledge